bonjour alexis poulain merci d'être avec
nous cet après midi sur rt france alors
on l'a dit un tome abonnés de la ligne à
quelques instants et des milliers
d'anonymes cet après midi pour rendre
hommage au professeur tué à vendredi et
des personnalités politiques également
que vous inspire ce rassemblement
c'était un rassemblement nécessaire pour
dire ton soutient que l'on peut apporter
à la famille de samuel pâtit mais aussi
à tous les professeurs qui sont en
première ligne
oublié trop souvent dans le travail
essentiel qu'ils font pour éduquer pour
élever les futurs citoyens que sont
leurs élèves
et je crois que c'était important
beaucoup de gens il y avait beaucoup de
professeurs bien sûr mais beaucoup de
gens qui étaient là bas parce qu'on ne
peut pas accepter en 2020 qu'un
professeur d'histoire-géographie
innocents se fasse décapité au nom d'une
fatwa qui a été lancé par quelques-uns
sur sur internet parce qu'il a il aurait
osé parler de liberté d'expression dans
son cours et montrer des caricatures les
caricatures on ne meurt pas pour des
desseins on ne meurt pas peur des
caricatures en france ça a suffit donc
je crois que ce rassemblement c'est
peut-être une chose qui était nécessaire
pour beaucoup on a l'habitude mais il
faut dépasser ce moment de l'hommage
il y en aura un autre un officiel cette
fois ci mercredi et arrêter aussi avec
la commisération les bougies aux
fenêtres etc et rentrer dans l'action
l'action réelle et la lutte contre
l'islamisme et je crois que gérald
darmanin a commencé à faire quelques
annonces de renvoi notamment de
d'individus qui ont été déjà condamnés
par la justice qui sont en prison plus
de deux cent trente et une personnes je
parle qui vont faire l'objet d'un renvoi
du territoire national donc ça c'est
extrêmement important
alexis blanc vous parliez d'action
à l'instant les politiques ont souvent
parlé d'unité depuis la tragédie de
vendredi
pas de représentant cet après midi des
républicains bruno retailleau sur
twitter a parlé je cite de trop dommage
son courage vous comprenez la position
du sénateur républicain je ne la
comprends pas parce que cette marche
elle est symbolique elle est je pense un
moment de recueillement elle est un
hommage à semelle pad qui la politique
c'est après et la politique elle est
indispensable parce que aujourd'hui pas
un petit bien pas un parti nenê absent
de critiques par rapport à son rapport à
l'islam isme par rapport à son axe isme
depuis les dernières années l air le
parti socialiste et également tous les
partis qui ont été au pouvoir ces
dernières années ont fait montre d'un
énorme laxisme ou bien d'un aveuglement
par rapport à ce danger à ce cancer
qu'est l'islamisme dans notre pays et
donc très bien c'est une façon d'éviter
de faire un audit de faire un bilan de
des ratages de ses nombreuses années
passées qui l'ont amené à la
décapitation de monsieur sam elle pâtit
mais il est temps que les politiques
maintenant soit responsable notamment ce
gouvernement au pouvoir et qu'ils
agissent pour tous ceux qui n'ont pas
fait ces années précédentes et ses
actions qui sont attendus bien c'est des
coups de filet dans le milieu islamiste
c'est le le renvoi des d aucune tf1 des
obligations de quitter le territoire
français quand elles sont signifiées
elles doivent être exécutés
immédiatement leur envoie également des
étrangers condamnés en prison et ceux
qui ont été condamnés mais qui sont
sortis à voir aussi comment gérald
darmanin va gérer tout ça la gestion du
renseignement des renseignements
généraux avec les fichiers s comment
s'assurer qu'on ne continue pas comme ça
et puis une grande question sur l'action
sur cette façon qu'ont certaines
associations politiques de l'islam
politique de pointé du doigt sur les
réseaux sociaux de lancer des fatwas
numérique sur certaines personnalités
comme leurs habitants et comme si nab et
d'autres qui dénonce l'islamisme et qui
eux continuent de montrer du doigt de
donner les adresses et voilà comment ça
peut se terminer puisque là certains
parlent d'un meurtre commandité
on est dans le cadre d'une commande de
tuer ce professeur de le d
capite pour l'exemple parce qu'il avait
osé poser mon dieu non il travaillait
montrer les dessins du prophète donc il
est temps que tout soit mis en place
pour que cet islamisme soit stoppé de
manière nette et immédiate dans notre
pays alexis paul ans vous avez évoqué un
quelques idées à l'instant pour lutter
contre l'islamisme radical conseil de
défense aujourd'hui autour d' emmanuel
macron qu'attendez-vous justement de ce
conseil de défense on sait qu emmanuel
macron pourrait éventuellement
s'exprimer ce soir
alors les discours comme je disais ça
suffit maintenant s'il s'exprime c'est
pour expliquer les actions qui vont être
mises en place une chose dans le cas de
samuel patyka tragique c'est que le
compte du jeune tchétchène qui a
décapité ce professeur avaient été
signalés un par la licra et avait fait
l'objet d'un signalement pharos dès le
mois de juillet 2020 rien n'a été fait
rien n'a été fait ce professeur avait
déposé plainte pour les nombreuses
menaces de mort il n'a pas été protégé
la république a failli donc il va
falloir remonter les responsabilités
voir aussi la responsabilité de la
hiérarchie de ce professeur parce que
trop souvent on a entendu les
professeurs lors de des attentats de
charlie hebdo dire qu'ils étaient
systématiquement lâché par la direction
et qu'il fallait pas faire de vagues ne
pas parler surtout des risques des
menaces au couteau des menaces d'élèves
qui eux aussi pointé du doigt le fait
qu'on n'osait débattre de la laïcité
audibert contre pression dans la classe
ou remettre en cause une religion unique
donc c'est important que les actions
suivent et de voir que ce ce qu'elles
vont peut-être
et puis on apprend que marlène schiappa
va recevoir les plateformes je crois
mardi ou mercredi au ministère de
l'intérieur pour voir comment organiser
la censure alors la censure c'est une
chose c'est la veille surtout qui compte
quand pharos et le signalement du compte
de ce jeune tchétchène en juillet
pourquoi rien à rien d'être enclenché
pourquoi rien ne se passe et qu'on
arrive au drame qui aurait peut-être pu
être évité de vendredi donc voilà il ya
beaucoup de choses à faire et j'espère
que l'on verra dans les jours qui
viennent une action énergique de la part
du gouvernement merci beaucoup alexis
poulain d'avoir été
avec nous aujourd'hui alexis poulain je
rappelle que vous êtes éditorialiste
pour arte france merci beaucoup